We surveyed experts across the country on what they plan on doing post-vaccination.
On travel, the answers were mixed.
Will you get on an airplane?
Not immediately.
Yes, I will.
Now that I've been vaccinated,...
...if I had to travel either for a family emergency or for work, I would.
I would not travel for pleasure at least yet.
The same for heading to a restaurant.
Will you eat indoors?
Yes, I would eat indoors because I'm still protected.
And then I would mask to protect others during ordering.
I do not plan to dine indoors until community rates are lower.
Their hesitation?
While your chance of getting sick when vaccinated is very low, you could still carry it.
While they all say they would avoid mass gathering indoors...
...like concerts and sporting events, they're split on small groups indoors.
Would you gather with friends inside?
I would gather only with vaccinated friends inside and have a dinner party.
No, I would be happy to continue hosting my backyard for small get-togethers.
Even returning to the gym, some more cautious than others.
Would you go to the gym?
I would go to the gym indoors.
In a few months.
If it were partially open with social distancing...
...and masking and good disinfection, probably.
Something many are looking forward to: a haircut while masked.
I would love to get a haircut.
If you look at this, this hair was cut by my 11-year-old daughter.
And one thing they all agree on:
Will you stop wearing a mask?
No.
Absolutely not.
I would not stop wearing a mask.